[Music]
we are taking a live look at Lee Canyon
this afternoon CCSD has another
three-day weekend coming up and for many
that means a trip to the snow but take
precautions pediatricians have the
following warnings and winter safety
tips before you head outdoors we don't
get snow around here very much so
sometimes we forget about these things
with more than nine feet of snow already
a very strong start to the ski
snowboarding and snowmobiling season at
Lee Canyon Dr Kerry wije singha of Siena
Pediatrics says kids need to be layered
up even more than adults here's a good
rule of thumb for clothing for older
infants mind you and children to have
them wear one extra layer compared to an
adult would do in the same situation
hence the snow hypothermia and Frostbite
are a real concern if you're not careful
outfit your kids in helmets for skiing
and snowboarding if you're planning on
sledding hats will keep the heat in
gloves and boots too pick a safe place
to avoid trees and crowds I see up there
in Kyle Canyon that um people are going
down Hills that have a lot of trees and
there can be injuries from that you can
be very seriously hurt snowmobiles pose
a significant risk to Children head
injuries Remain the leading cause of
death among 15 to 24 year olds when
snowmobiles Collide fall or overturn
where the proper gear helmet and goggles
only kids who are 16 and older should be
operating one if they're younger than
six they shouldn't be on one at all as
for ice skating plenty of safe places
indoor and outdoor around town for that
but if you're headed out of town
if you're out in Utah say make sure it's
approved to be on that certain Lake and
make sure to go in the same direction
because injuries Dr wijay singha says
can happen when people go the wrong way
it's also important to keep an emergency
kit in your car that includes a
flashlight extra batteries a first aid
kit and extra medicine